the situation in afghanistan is so bad
and so humiliating for the united states
that it's easy to forget the bite
administration is control of this
country as well so what they've been
doing to us well that's been going on
we've tried to keep at least one eye
open to find out well it turns out the
byte administration has been completely
remaking the federal judiciary as the
rest of us have been focused on
afghanistan in just the past three
months without many people noticing it
at all the administration has gotten a
remarkable number
of its judges through joe biden has
nominated 33 of them nine of those
judges have already been confirmed many
more soon will follow so for perspective
no president in the past 40 years has
come close to these numbers by this
point in his first term
many of these judges the inviting
administration will admit this are
full-blown political activists not
jurists they're left-wing ideologues
they're people like myrna perez who joe
biden has just appointed to one of the
most important courts in the country the
second circuit court of appeals mourinho
prez has spent the last 15 years
campaigning against voter id laws anyone
who wants voter id according to bruno
perez must be a racist
right before her confirmation hearings
began perez wrote a piece for a social
justice magazine in which she railed
against quote the gop campaign to make
elections less free less free
showing a state ideas you do to get on
an airplane or by sudafed at walgreens
so you would expect the biden
administration to flood the judiciary
with lunatics like this they want power
and partisan judges will help ensure
that that power goes completely
unchecked here's what you wouldn't
expect
and that's one of the most prominent
members of the so-called conservative
party to spend his time helping the
buyer administration do that but that's
happening it's exactly what's happening
this summer the senate judiciary
committee voted to advance murder
president's comment confirmation every
republican on the panel voted no except
for one do you know who that was it was
lindsey graham of south carolina now why
would lindsey graham support the
confirmation of someone like bernard
perez well to answer that question it
helps know that this is hardly an
isolated case we checked
lindsey graham is the only republican on
the judiciary committee who has not
voted to reject a single judge the bide
administration has proposed no matter
how crazy they are
for procedural reasons in a senate split
50 50 lindsey graham's support matters
very much senate aides tell us that
because of lindsey graham one man the
biden administration is able to rush its
nominees through the senate confirmation
process faster than any other president
in memory so the most radical president
of our lifetimes gets the most judges
confirmed thanks to lindsey graham now
those nominees include someone that many
democrats hope to see in the supreme
court soon that would be an activist
called kentaji brown jackson jackson is
a former trial judge who spent the last
four years writing political orders for
the benefit of jerry nadler and nancy
pelosi
for example brown once wrote an opinion
comparing the previous administration to
an illegal monarchy
that decision was so crazy that the dc
court of appeals which leads to the left
reversed it not once but twice
but it was good enough for lindsey
graham who voted in favor of brown's
confirmation
that's because lindsey graham in case
you didn't notice spent most of last
year begging for your money money from
conservatives at all hours on cable
television has no problem installing
judges who hate his constituents and you
shouldn't be surprised by that a few
years ago graham admitted in an
interview with politico that his
overriding political ambition was to
quote stay relevant not to represent his
voters or keep the left from destroying
the country but to ingratiate himself
with the people in power and advance his
own interests
so in that respect lindsey graham has
done exactly what he said he would the
question is why are conservatives
continuing to promote him and allowing
him to continue to sit on the judiciary
committee well we would love to ask that
question of lindsey graham himself
we've asked him many times to come on
the show but he refuses because he's
afraid and that's a shame that would be
a very interesting fact-based
conversation
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else